hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between paul charles morphy and
adolf andersen and this is game 11. so
in game 10 if you've been following
what's been happening so far morphe had
the opportunity to end the match
completely because the match is the
rules of the match are first the seven
wins that wins the match and morphy
already has six wins and uh
well he could have ended it but anderson
got his second win and now uh maybe
anderson can bounce back in the match
but he will still need to win a lot of
games he only won two so far and that's
uh uh against morphy even that is
considered a lot but if he can win five
more then he wins the match so let's see
what happens in this one uh as here
anderson will again try a very very
interesting opening but that involves a
very uh interesting story uh about this
opening but we'll get to that so morphe
with the white pieces in game 11 opens
with e4 and anderson goes for e6 he
chooses the french defense for his 11th
game uh d4 we have g6 now uh and bishop
to d3 with bishop to g7 and now the ship
to e3 again morphy places his bishops on
d3 and then e3 and uh staunton's are not
staunton sorry eleventh levanthal says
that this is considered somewhat of a
novelty uh but not really what the
morphe is doing here he's repeating a
game anderson already played in 1851 if
you remember we mentioned that anderson
won a great tournament in london in 1851
and he had the disposition against none
other than howard staunton uh and that
game was a was a very interesting one uh
but uh we're we're gonna
discuss it a little bit more but
basically uh lumenthal says that the
student cannot fail of observing that in
almost every fringe game a mystery that
mr morphy plays his bishops are on e3
and on d3
and they appear well placed there and
come into efficient action when called
upon it is a novelty however in chess
play and will doubtless meet with
attention at the hands of authors of the
game
uh so um
although it's not actually a novelty uh
i guess morphy knows what he's doing
because he was preparing to meet
staunton and of course he probably uh
studied all of staunton's games so now
he's a very well versed in you know the
the secrets of this opening uh but but
not really and this is what i mean here
anderson plays c5 and this move
is a move that staunton also played
against him uh in london in 1851 but
it's a it's a terrible move now we know
it's a terrible move but in those days i
guess it was considered standard
practice i mean white grabbed the center
with the d4 and e4 uh makes sense to
challenge him with c5 sort of a sicilian
dragon type of type of idea uh but the
problem is uh black can very happily
capture this uh
if d captures on c5 is played and now
black captures this on b2 we simply play
knight d2 and if black captures the rook
this position is well close to winning
for white how do you how do you defend
the rook uh you can play knight f6 then
bishop to g5 and if you play f6 well
then knight to c for the knight is
coming to d6 and it's just a terrible
terrible position for for black the the
the dark square weaknesses around the
black king are
will be ever present there's no fixing
that and this is well they're already
very close to winning
uh so interestingly uh morphy doesn't
capture d captures on c5 he just plays
c3 defends the center like anderson did
against staunton in the london
tournament of 1851
and now comes c character c captures and
now we uh take a different path than the
the then uh staunton did here anderson
plays knight to c6 and this is a fine
move but uh
uh staunton played queen to b6 he was a
greedy and went after that b2 pawn and
then the game continued knight to e2 uh
staunton grabbed the pawn knight beat
the c3 and now you have to go back rook
to b1 is coming so queen to b6 uh and
now anderson played rook to c1 and he
won a very nice game nice game basically
all of his pieces are already developed
but even stronger than anderson's rook 8
to c1 is knight to b5 this is just
completely crushing uh there's no no
real way for black to continue uh any
any sort of development here that's just
uh i mean
there's d5 opening up a discovery to the
queen you can't really continue
developing if you play something like
knight f6 then then e5 is coming and if
knight to d5 for example knight the d6
check is then possible now we have a
nice outpost here and this is just uh
well lost for black
but okay after knight c after c captures
on d4 we have knight to c6 by anderson
and now it's basically as as of move six
that we have a completely new game but a
lot of consideration went into this so
morphe continues knight to e2 not knight
g to e7 we have castles by both players
and the now knight beat the c3 and here
uh anderson strikes in the center with
the d5 and the black got a very
comfortable position which should not be
possible you know he played the french
his light square bishop will very soon
be developed it doesn't sound like it
should be possible uh that's because
it's not because anderson also played
that c5 move which should lose you the
game on the spot but uh you know it
worked and now he has a he has a fairly
comfortable game so e5 and now anderson
uh tries to undermine the center with f6
uh morphe plays f4 uh not f3 morphy
plays f4 and now we have f captures on
e5 f captures and now a6 uh
played like there is really nothing in
the position but morphy doesn't agree
morphy plays queen to d2 he's ready to
exchange uh the dark square bishops also
bishop to g5 will be very annoying and
he has his rooks connected whereas
anderson still needs to develop the
light square bishop somehow uh to
connect his rooks and try to use the f
file for for his own work so here we
have knight to b4 uh attacking morphy's
bishop on d3 but morphy doesn't care uh
you can't really save the bishop bishop
to b1 is not an option because the rook
is still on a1 so just bishop to g5
anderson grabs the light square bishop
morphe captures and now bishop to d7
anderson is now ready to get his other
rook into the game hopefully develop the
queen somehow but it's still very
difficult to connect the rooks you can't
move the queen the knight will be
hanging here if you try some h6 moves
then
well your king is already
you know filling the draft you don't
want to make it even worse so here
morphe goes queen to h3
it's a very very very strong move the
problem is if anderson continues
recklessly let's say he plays b5 wants
to play rook to c8 and so on queen h4
there's a double attack on the knight
and now what do you do you have to
defend it rook rook to e8 and good luck
on pinning this there's i mean the queen
will never be able to move the knight
will not be able to move and you know uh
white has such a good position that he
could even probably afford some like
knights to d1 to e3 to g4 to f6 just to
you know uh win the game without um
without much trouble but okay after
queen to h3 anderson plays the absolute
best move he just unpins now the knight
can move to f5 if needed and uh here
morphy just continues with knights to g3
if this was a modern game we would no
doubt see a move like g4 preventing this
knife from reaching f5 but morphe says
no this is not a problem i'm going to
play knight to g3 and now anderson just
continues development uh rook the c8
still waiting with this knight to f5
move uh and now uh morphy trades off a
pair of rooks so he waited uh
just the right time to trade off uh this
pair of rooks so this rook can come
to f1 with tempo so rook captures an f8
queen captures now rook to f1 again the
queen has to keep an eye on the knight
so queen to e8 and now queen to h4 now
there's a double attack on the knight
and uh you have to decide here whether
to
defend it uh well maybe a bit of a
passive move bishop to f8 but it gets
the job done and it's not easy for
morphy to
organize some sort of an attack here but
anderson decides to go for the more
active move knight to f5 uh and this is
now a problem uh morphe now just
captures the knight we have knight
captures on f5
and the reason this is good is because
you have to play g characters on f5 if
you play e characters then you lose this
pawn and then morphy has to connect it
uh past pawns in the center of course a
completely winning position so after
knight captures an f5 g captures on f5
was played but now uh we uh have access
uh well
along the h file and here uh our good
friend the rook says bonjour and he
plays rook to f3 now rook is coming to
h3 maybe to g3 and it's not going to be
easy bishop to f6 instead of rook to f3
also works but you know we're going to
play both of those moves so it doesn't
really matter in what order
and now anderson has to
find a good move but there doesn't seem
to be a good move uh if you trade off
the dark square bishop then you're
basically left with a light square
bishop and all of your pawns are on
light square so it's basically your
bishop will be like a pawn i mean that's
already positionally lost so you have to
figure out how to play this uh h5 is one
such move that maybe allows anderson to
remain in the game not allowing this
bishop to h6 or bishop to f6 ideas now
the pawn is nicely defended if morphy
wants morph he could go after it with
rook to h3 but i think to survive the
attack anderson will gladly give up upon
and you know try and fight with this
with his bishop pair
but okay here after rook to f3 anderson
played bishop to b5 he says i'm just
going to put my bishop here it's not
doing all that much but you know if you
ever want to capture it uh at least i'm
going to get rid of my useless bishop so
here morphy plays rook to g3 now he's
aligning the rook with the king bishop
to f6 is coming
rook to c7 adding another defender here
and now bishop to f6
and here uh there really isn't a good
move for anderson because the position
is uh so beautiful that
you can win it any way you want but it's
actually really really simple so what
white just needs to do is let's say you
capture the bishop black captures and
you play queen to h6 and that's it
there's really no no way of defending
this and then you will have all the time
in the world to improve your position
before trading all of your pieces on the
g7 square and just winning the end game
now we're going to discuss this a little
bit more just so it becomes
clearer but here anderson played f4 and
morphe praises this move uh he says that
this is the only move that basically
fends off the attack but uh i will show
you one line and here we're going to
have a pause the video moment in this
hypothetical line that didn't happen and
this is uh our good friend uh uh
yohanyako blumenthal says that morphe uh
comments on this after this game uh and
he says uh had anderson played king to
h8 it's a very straightforward victory
in only like 13 14 moves and this is the
line that morphe gives so if
if anderson and pinned morphy would
trade right away rook characters and g7
rook captures on g7 knight captures and
b5 queen captures and b5 you don't want
to ruin your pawn structure queen to h6
now threatening checkmate queen to d7
defending checkmate and now we have the
position that we discussed now white can
play any move that white wants and he
can improve the position as much as he
wants before trading here because black
really doesn't have an option here so
this is the line that morphe gives h4
black uh has to wait move waste moves
there's nothing to be done here we're
going to play h5 now black again has to
wait moves queen to c7 now we're going
to play a3
improve our position as much as possible
queen to d7 and now king to f2 even
bring the king into the game queen to f7
we're going to play king to f3 and after
queen to c7 let's say we're going to
play g3 and now after queen to d7
finally we trade everything on the g7
square queen captures queen captures uh
and now comes h6 this is the move that
morphe had in mind queen captures on f6
e captures on f6 and now king to g8 we
have came to f4 and here morphy says uh
well morphy says something but i'm not
going to tell you what morphy says here
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the only move that doesn't lose
for black while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that doesn't lose for anderson
in this hypothetical line uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rooked aking to f8 gaining
the long opposition here and now it's
not going to be possible for white to
win this but in his uh analysis after
the game morphy said king to f7 and
white just wins the game with king to e5
and while this is true uh you don't have
to play king to f7 now it's hard to say
if morphe actually said this maybe uh
love intel just said that morphy said
this so he could maybe criticize him
although he doesn't criticize him now
until just you know uh gives the
variation without commenting on it uh
at all uh but it wasn't uh uncommon for
players you know after the game to
analyze the the position uh blindfold so
they didn't really move the pieces over
the board they would just uh you know uh
discuss moves so maybe this is something
that morphe missed but the the position
is you know even uh before this is the
winning in so many ways that uh
of course if uh if anderson actually
played king to itch it i i don't see
that morphe would would make this
mistake uh but after a king to f7 of
course the the position is now nicely
winning for white uh but uh you know
after after king to f8 uh you you don't
really have a win uh if you try king to
e5 then the position can even
go very wrong for you now king to f7 and
now white is the one that has to move
and allow king captures on f6 you don't
really have a way if you try and uh you
know just to waste some moves here you
will run out of moose and you're going
to have to move your king we're going to
capture on f6 and black is the one
that's going to be winning so here if
if king 2fa displayed morphe would have
to play g4 you know just for the for the
fun of the position captures captures
now king f7 king g5 and now we have a
draw king to g8 king to f4 and now king
to f8 king to g4 so again not allowing
you uh not allowing black to gain uh the
upper hand king to f7 we're gonna play
king to g5 everything is fine this is a
draw uh just something i wanted to you
know
show you because it's a lot of fun uh
but here king the h8 was not played
anderson played f4 and morphy said all
right this is a move that really ruins
my attack but only only briefly so queen
captures on f4 uh and now queen to f8 uh
so what do you play here knight captures
on b5 it's not a problem now the queen
covers the c1 square so you don't have
rook to c1 check a captures on b5 and
now queen to h6 so basically uh morphe
gets pretty much the the same position
only now black is down upon and his uh
pawns on the queen side are doubled so
it's uh well
much much better than the line uh morphe
discussed after queen after king to h8
so now king the h8 anderson and pins but
now morphy just captures rook captain g7
rook captures and again there's no rush
here we've reached the position from the
thumbnail now murphy starts improving
the position he's going to move some
pawns move the king if anderson allows
it anderson does not allow it he plays
king to g8 and now you have to
capture because now the the rook can
move so queen captures sun g7 queen
captures with bishop captures king
captures and now king to f3 so now
morphy has a
better position he's up upon this is now
completely winning for him we have b4 by
anderson we have g4 by morphe and now b6
we have h4 now comes b5 and now king to
e3 now morphe will simply bring his king
over here pick up the pawns and win the
game so anderson plays b3 tries to mess
up morphe spawn structure by giving up
another pawn and while capturing on b3
is still winning for morphy i think
morphy wanted to end the game uh in a
poetic fashion and he played a3 so here
it was in this position uh on move uh
36 that out of anderson resigned in the
game and with it the entire match as
morphe now has seven wins uh and i i
think it's beautiful that more that the
move that ended the match is pawn to a3
which is the move that anderson employed
in three of the games and basically the
the move that gave morphe the most
trouble in the match even though uh in
that um opening uh we called it the
grand opening of morphe one one lost one
and one game ended in a draw uh anderson
had a
well just a great position in all three
games and you know it could have gone uh
either way uh but i think the turning
point in the match was a game three uh
after which anderson no longer wanted to
reply e5 to morphy's e4 because that
game just didn't go well for him and
then he just you know lost five in a row
so i i think it could have
been a much different match but we don't
have to guess because this is not the
only match the two of them have played
and we're gonna
show this match as well uh it is our
next destination in the morphe saga
because the match took place the next
day so uh they all got together and they
were ready to get a group photograph and
while they were waiting for
photographers to you know set everything
up they played a match it took three
hours and they played six games and all
six games featured the king's gambit so
yes the next in the morphe saga is
another match between morphe and
anderson where king's gambit will be
played in all six games yes i know it's
hard to believe that uh something uh you
know this good exists uh but you know it
it does and and we're gonna enjoy it
uh and then we'll see what happens uh in
the morphe saga after that
uh so uh if any of you are interested
the final game of the match took place
on 28th of december so a little bit
before new year's uh and this game
lasted for for four hours so we're ready
for the next day for their match and
well that's it for this match morphe
wins it with a with a with a result of
um seven wins to two and two of the
games were drawn and as uh anderson uh
so finally states uh in the quote above
the board morphy is the finest chess
player who ever existed he is far
superior to any now living and would
doubtless have beaten la bordene himself
uh well there is no way for us to know
this i i think chances are that morphe
morphe would definitely crush him
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna discuss uh more
about the morphe saga after uh after the
other match against anderson but that's
that's it for now uh so yeah i would
like to thank tom darrell happy birthday
will uh simon novak gordon gottman and
harry walk for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day